demain sourire à oslo la conférence
internationale contre le travail des
enfants une nouvelle fois l' esclavage
des petits mise en évidence
malgré les lois et les conventions qui
se multiplient des millions d'enfants
seraient réduits à l'état d'esclaves un
peu partout dans le monde
nathalie moisan images d'un autre âge
le calvaire des enfants esclaves des
mines de charbon c'est aujourd'hui en
colombie plusieurs parents décidé
d'aider ces enfants
ravier a passé cinq ans dans cette mine
aujourd'hui il va à l'école leur aviez
quand tu retournes dans la mine
à quoi ça te fait penser quand tu es
dans la mine une toute petite pause n'y
en a pas parce que c'est tellement
fatiguant le patron te pousse à
continuer c'est dur alors tu te dis mais
pourquoi diable un enfant comme moi fait
travailler comme ça là
dans cette tannerie égyptienne les
enfants travaillent à proximité des
barriques de produits dangereux pour
l'unicef ils sont 250 millions dans le
monde à mettre en danger leur santé ou à
risquer leur vie au travail
certains diront que nous devons nous
attaquer la pauvreté en priorité car
c'est la cause du travail des enfants
mais on ne peut pas attendre sur la
question du travail dangereux
les gouvernements et le public aussi
doivent se soulever contre les dangers
un travail des enfants en soustraire les
enfants aux risques de maladie
c'est la priorité de l'unicef ainsi dans
cette usine indienne où l'on poli le
diamant le travail laisse les enfants
admis aveugle ou malades des poumons
d'axa n'a que 14 ans son certificat de
naissance le prouve
l'embarras de son patron le confirme
pourquoi vous l'employez 14 ans trop
jeune
c'est la pauvreté comment vous
l'expliquez son père et pauvres très
pauvres les enfants du tiers-monde
fabrice également des chaussures des
chemises ou des vêtements pour de
grandes marques occidentales
la conférence d'oslo aura aussi pour but
d'attirer l'attention des consommateurs
que nous sommes sur ses pratiques et à
bruxelles